trois mois après avoir pris le contrôle
du centre de tri de la Chine la société
via a de bonnes nouvelles on est passé
de 30% de matière non désirée des choses
qui ne vont pas au dans ces vélos là à
8,10 % des ballots de papier 3 fois
moins contaminés mais que l'on continue
d'exporter en grande majorité je dirais
qu'il y a à peu près 20% du papier
mélangé qui est vendu localement puis la
balance est exportée vers l'Asie à la
différence de recova dont le contrat a
été résilié l'été dernier à la Chine le
nouvel opérateur emploie une quarantaine
de personnes pour le tri c'est environ
deux fois plus
de lumière encore une fois ça va fort
que les gens ici sont performants pour
trouver ce qui va pas recyclage c'est
leur travail principal rejeté d'emblée
des choses qui vont pas leur le taux de
rejet ici est de 18% donc près d'un
objet sur 5 qui ne devrait pas se
retrouver dans le bac l'essentiel de ce
qui est recyclé ensuite c'est le papier
puis le carton et le verre le plastique
et enfin le métal ça devrait redonner
confiance au mont et aller dans le
recyclage hebdomadaire l'entreprise
recova qui garde un contrat pour le
centre de tri de Saint Michel jusqu'en
septembre 2024 annonce une performance
encore plus grande nous avons réduit les
taux de contamination de 35 % à 2 %
grâce à l'acquisition de Triors optiques
européens au coup de 6 millions de
dollars la Ville de Montréal se félicite
des avancées dans les deux centres de
tri mais elle tient à demander une
caractérisation externe qui validera la
performance car le taux de 2% et le
fruit d'une caractérisation faite à
l'interne parikova l'entreprise qui trie
le recyclage de toute la partie Est de
l'île de Montréal assure qu'elle a un
taux de rejet aussi bas que 8%. ce qui
voudrait dire que les Montréalais trient
bien à l'ouest de la diacre de 10% à
Montréal même sur l'île entre l'Est et
l'Ouest
j'avoue que là j'ai une certaine réserve
sans mettre en doute la bonne foi de
l'opérateur il demandent aussi que le
taux de contamination soit validé par
une expertise externe ici Mathieu Prost
Radio-Canada Montréal